I was looking at some uh predictions
from 1923 for the year 2023 and uh some
of the headlines there were were things
like we should worry because women will
be shaving their heads and men will be
wearing curls also they were saying that
we would all now in 20123 only be
working a 4-Hour day owing to the work
of electricity and we would all be using
utensils made from Pulp and uh humans
would be living um at least to 100 years
and in some cases up to 200 years now
that's not exactly right but you can see
some of those signals there the way in
which we have a completely different
view of gender and identity for example
the world's biggest trial of the reduced
working week has just been completed
successfully you know we are all living
longer not quite to 200 years so there
are some signals there but I think the
key issue is we don't even bother to
look for those
signals